le rondo dans les parcelles est devenu
une habitude pour eux ces enfants le
travail depuis près d'un an et demi avec
l'orchestré demos le dispositif
d'éducation musicale et orchestrale à
vocation sociale de la philharmonie de
paris et répète deux fois par semaine
ils apprennent la musique en collectif
avec des professeurs de la philharmonie
paris dans leurs structures sociales
dans leur centre de loisirs dans le p r
e enfin chaque ville détermine une
structure sociale qui va porter le
projet ce sont des enfants qui a priori
n'aurait pas pousser les portes d'un
conservatoire n'aurait pas pratiquer la
musique classique et donc le projet
demos ses valeurs c'est d'aller vers la
démocratisation culturelle et l'accès à
une forme de culture en l'occurrence la
culture classique depuis novembre 2016
ils sont entourés de musiciens
professionnels d'un chef d'orchestre de
la philharmonie et d'encadrants nous on
est là pour leur apprendre la technicité
de l'instrument qu'ils ont choisi et
également de les ouvrir et de leur faire
écouter beaucoup de styles de musique
différents des notions de formation
musicale d'ecoute dans leur cas striby
mois une centaine d'enfants dont des
very roi des trappistes et des plaisirs
oit j'avais un peu de mal à jouer
après après je suis rentré mais je me
suis entraîné j'ai pas lâcher ça va il
ya les professeurs qui nous aide si on
n'arrive pas et dans les cours
particuliers appelés dia il ya ma
professeure du violon qui m'aident à
celle ci le premier de ma famille on
s'est donc là la fierté d'avoir moi je
suis très heureuse de jouer de la
musique je me dis que j'ai de la chance
de pouvoir faire ça après des concerts
dans les yvelines leur dernier rendez
vous est à paris à la cité de la musique
il vous emmène en voyage avec elle ou
500 s'est cogné alice une musique
traditionnelle gréco turque
ouais